you guys have changed my life with my
blush so thank you thank you thank you
for that Selena Gomez returns to tick
tock and admits her heart has been heavy
amid recent rumored Haley Bieber drama
I'm really big on vulnerability on
Sunday the only murders in the building
star shared a makeup tutorial featuring
products from her Cosmetics line I gotta
be honest type of horrible horrible
eyeshadow I don't know what I'm doing I
just do things that
I feel pretty on me in the comments
Selena shares a personal message with
fans writing that she's deeply grateful
and you make me unbelievably happy I
feel free more than I've ever felt in my
whole life but when it comes to the fan
frenzy surrounding Selena and her ex
Justin Bieber's wife Haley Bieber Selena
has one request remember to be
[Music]
kindness quote please please be kinder
and consider others mental health my
heart has been heavy and I only want
good for everyone I'm being honest and I
think that's just who I am of course
this all comes after fans speculated
Haley and Kylie Jenner were bullying
Selena on Instagram after cell shared
this clip referencing her newly done
brows I accidentally laminated my brows
too much shortly after that Kylie posted
this snap writing this was an accident
over her brows and shared a close-up pic
of Haley's brows at the time Kylie
denied the post was about Selena calling
the whole thing silly Selena agreed and
said the drama was unnecessary but even
before all that some fans accused Haley
and Kendall Jenner of subtly dissing
Selena in a since deleted Tick Tock and
I'm not saying she deserved it but I'm
saying God's timing is always right when
one tick tocker posted about the theory
Selena hopped into the comments with
it's okay I don't let these things get
me down be nice to everyone I want them
to know it's okay but things came to a
head when a clip resurfaced online of
Haley gagging At The Mention Of cell's
bestie Taylor Swift full of the meanest
lyrics about a celebrity since Taylor
Swift's last album
talk cell gave her two cents in the
comments writing so sorry my best friend
is and continues to be one of the best
in the game on social media it's as much
as it's a blessing and it's fun it it
can really tear people down and I always
hope that the people I'm involved with
or support me can just kind of spread
love within that that's when Selena
announced during a Tick-Tock live that
she was taking time away from social
media this is a little silly and I'm 30
I'm too old for this so
I love you guys so much
you guys
um sooner than later well she's now
officially back on the platform I love
you guys so much thank you
but before she returned she soaked up
some quality time with family sharing
these snaps on Instagram writing that
she's grateful thankful and a blessed
lady
[Music]